Wenn ich arm bin habe ich die Möglichkeit,
vor allem in Deutschland, mehr
zu arbeiten, mehr zu investieren und ein Vermögen
daraus zu machen. Aber ich hab's
-doch geschafft.
-Ich bin schwarz und ich bin
schwerbehindert und ich hatte
scheiß Einstiegschancen.
13 Fragen. Hier kommt die erste: Ist
Erben gerecht? Wenn ihr sagt Ja, dann bitte
auf dem grünen Feld positionieren. Und wenn ihr sagt
Nein, das ganze System muss
dringend reformiert werden, dann bitte
auf dem gelben Feld positionieren. Und bitte!
So, vielen Dank, jetzt wissen wir, wo ihr steht.
Aber wo steht ihr? In Deutschland
werden pro Jahr rund 200 bis 400
Milliarden Euro vererbt oder verschenkt
und das weitgehend steuerfrei. Also
eine gewaltige Summe. Und der größte Anteil
dieses Erbschaftskuchens geht an diejenigen,
die ohnehin schon das meiste
Vermögen haben. Ganz wertfrei
gesagt verstärkt also Erben die finanzielle
Ungleichheit. Ja gut, sagen die einen,
meine Familie hat ja auch viel Lebenszeit
und viel Energie in den Aufbau
des Vermögens gesteck, vielleicht sogar
ein Unternehmen gegründet,
Arbeitsplätze geschaffen und obendrein noch gespart.
Und jetzt kommt ihr und wollt das den Nachkommen
wegnehmen? Wie ungerecht ist
das denn? Ja, Moment, sagen die anderen.
Erbschaft, das ist ja erstmal
leistungsloses Vermögen. Das heißt,
du hast dafür erstmal gar nichts getan.
Nur weil du zufälligerweise das große
Los in der Eizellen-Lotterie gezogen hast,
bist du jetzt reich und zum Beispiel
Die Tochter einer Krankenpflegerin ist arm.
Pure Glückssache. Wie ungerecht ist
das denn? Irgendwo auf den zwei Seiten
dieser Konfliktlinie haben sich
natürlich auch meine heutigen Gäste positioniert.
Die spannende Frage ist: Wie kriegen
wir sie wieder zusammen? Denn bei 13 Fragen
geht's ja um Kompromisse. Also
es wird spannend zu sehen sein, ob uns
ein Kompromiss gelingt oder sogar
ein Lösungsvorschlag. Wo würdet ihr euch
positionieren, auf grün: Ja, das Erbschaftssystem
ist so insgesamt schon
ganz okay, oder auf gelb: Nein, es muss
dringend reformiert werden. Schreibt
es mir gerne in die Kommentare.
Die Spielregeln sind ja ganz einfach:
Wenn ihr im Laufe der Diskussion
glaubt, die Gegenseite hat da einen Punkt,
dann würde ich euch bitten, kommt
einen Schritt auf sie zu. Und wenn ihr sagt,
das, was du jetzt erzählst, ist
totaler Quatsch, dann könnt ihr einen Schritt
zurückgehen, also euch ein bisschen
entfernen. Das Ziel, mein Ziel ist es,
am Ende möglichst viele von euch hier
in diese Mitte zu bringen, auf das sogenannte
Kompromissfeld auf, in der Hoffnung,
dass wir irgendeine Lösung finden
in dieser Diskussion. Soweit alles
klar? Gut, hier kommt Frage Nummer zwei
und die geht an Marlene: Deiner
Familie gehört zu einer der reichsten
in Österreich. Das heißt, du wirst
mal sehr, sehr viel Geld erben. Die meisten
Leute würden sich darüber sehr freuen.
Du ärgerst dich darüber. Warum?
Es kommt drauf an, was man betrachtet.
Also grundsätzlich: Über ein Geschenk kann
man sich schon freuen, aber wenn man
sieht, dass da eine strukturelle
Ungleichheit vererbt wird, dann muss
man sich schon fragen: Okay, auf wessen Kosten
geht denn hier mein Reichtum? Wer hat
es denn erarbeitet? Wer sieht davon nichts
und warum nicht? Dass die Verteilungsfrage
nicht demokratisch, öffentlich,
transparent und gerecht geregelt
wird, ist eigentlich ein politischer Skandal.
Ich möchte mein Erbe umverteilen lassen
von einem demokratischen Staat, damit das,
was alle was angeht, nämlich wie Geld
verwaltet wird, in demokratischen Händen
passiert und nicht von Einzelpersonen
entschieden wird. Ich habe nichts
für dieses Erbe getan. Und wenn man
sich diese Fragen mal konsequent zu Ende
auskaspert, inklusive der Frage:
Wie viel ist genug? Was ist das gute Leben
für alle? Nach dem demokratischen
Prinzip "Was alle was angeht, sollten alle
entscheiden." Dann überlegt man schon:
Macht das wirklich Sinn, wenn eine Person
so viel Geld bekommt? Zumal das ja
mit Macht einhergeht, mit Lebenschancen.
Ich kann mir auch bequem die Medien
einkaufen gehen, die Politik einkaufen
gehen, die Wirtschaft einkaufen
gehen, das ist jetzt auch nicht unüblich
und ich denke, das hat dann
mit Demokratie nichts mehr zu tun.
Wir haben ja zwei Frauen, die beide
erben oder erben werden. Anastasia, du gehörst
ja auch dazu. Aber du sagst: Ne,
höhere Erbschaftssteuer nicht, das finde
-ich ungerecht. Warum?
-Also meine Mutter ist alleinerziehend. Sie
hat sich das alles selber aufgebaut.
Ich habe eben dieses Argument: Meine Mama
hatte keine Zeit für mich. Meine Mutter
hat gearbeitet, war bei Veranstaltungen,
hat PR gemacht, während ich zuhause
war. Aber im großen Ganzen das,
was ich gegründet habe, nämlich mein Start-up
FeMentor, was der Gesellschaft
etwas zurückgibt, kam daher, dass ich dieses Polster
meiner Mutter hatte,
was sie mit Verzicht aufgebaut hat.
Mein Leben verändert sich durch das Wissen,
dass ich irgendwann erben werde, dass ich weiß,
ich kann dieses Social Start-up
jetzt führen, ohne mir Gedanken zu machen,
wie ich mein Studium finanziere,
ohne dass ich mir Gedanken machen
muss, wie ich meine Wohnung finanziere,
weil meine Mutter mir gesagt hat,
ich investiere in dich, ich investiere
in deine Zukunft, auch wenn ich dafür
auf gewisse Dinge verzichten muss.
Also dein Argument ist ja
eigentlich: Deine Mutter hat sich den Popo
abgearbeitet, damit du es gut
hast oder vielleicht sogar besser hast,
als sie es mal hatte. Und das wäre dann
ungerecht, wenn man dir das Geld wegnehmen
würde, was deine Mutter
erarbeitet hat. Richtig?
Es ist ungerecht, weil ich auf Zeit
verzichten musste und weil ich immer
darauf vorbereitet worden bin, was Soziales
zurückzugeben. Meine Mutter ist
immer mit mir in arme Länder gereist,
weil ich kein Geschwisterchen habe, um mir
zu zeigen, dass Teilen wichtig ist,
dass es wichtig ist, etwas zurückzugeben.
Meine Mutter hat auch Jobs
angenommen, die gar nicht oder wenig bezahlt waren,
um das auszugleichen, dass sie gesagt
hat: Ich hab meinen Job, in dem ich supergut
verdiene und davon lege ich alles
zurück, um eben auch soziale Projekte zu machen.
Wolfgang, warum willst
du ihr ihr Geld wegnehmen?
Das mag ja ganz löblich sein, dass es da einige
Charity Ambitionen gibt. Nur kann
man das ja nicht den Reichen
überlassen, dass sie entscheiden, ob sie vielleicht
was abgeben oder nicht, sondern dass ist
einfach eine demokratische Frage und Macht
ist in einer Demokratie geteilt und die wird
auch nicht vererbt. Kapital bedeutet
vererbte Macht. Und deshalb muss man
auch da besteuern. Und dass man sagt na ja,
deswegen war so wenig Zeit da und die Mutter
hat da ein Polster aufgebaut.
Viele Leute können sich gar kein
Polster aufbauen, weil die Löhne so niedrig sind
und sie auch nicht gestiegen sind,
während das Kapital immer weiter steigt.
Wir müssen uns das eigentlich
vorstellen, wie bei einem 100-Meter-Lauf: Die,
die geerbt haben, die stehen
eigentlich schon am Ziel und die anderen versuchen,
das Ziel zu erreichen und schaffen das gar
nicht mehr. Deshalb müssen wir das Erbe
umverteilen und deshalb ist es so,
wie es jetzt gerade ist, nicht gerecht.
Man darf auch nicht verwechseln:
Strukturelle und individuelle Lage,
also das Modell von deiner Mutter ist
löblich, aber das kann nicht für alle so
gelten. Und wir wollen das ja nicht
für alle so haben. Und deshalb bedeutet das:
-Wir müssen eine andere Struktur schaffen.
-Es geht darum um Barvermögen. Und es geht
darum, wenn man eine Immobilie
erbt. Eine Immobilie wird auch versteuert.
Bei der Erbschaftssteuer werden
Immobilien und der ganze Besitz mit eingerechnet.
-Das gesamte Vermögen.
-Genau, das ganze Vermögen. Das heißt meine
Mutter, wenn sie damals eine Wohnung
gekauft hat, die in DDR oder BRD Zeiten
viel, viel weniger wert war vom Preis,
dass man sich damals noch Mieten
und generell Wohnungskäufe leisten
konnte. Und jetzt durch das Betongold ist
diese Wohnung unglaublich viel
wert. Deshalb bin ich allein schon über
diesen 400.000 Euro Betrag, von dem ich mir
vielleicht gar nicht leisten kann,
eine Wohnung und eine Immobilie
heißt nicht, dass ich nie wieder zahlen muss.
Ich wollte gerne Marlenes Vorschlag
aufgreifen und aufs Strukturelle gehen,
auf die Meta-Ebene. Gerd, also
wir haben Marlene gehört, die sagt:
Aus strukturellen Gründen, auch aus demokratischen
Gründen habe ich gehört,
ist es sinnvoll, dass wir eine höhere
Erbschaftssteuer haben. Du sagst genau
-das Gegenteil. Warum?
-Marlene würde ich sagen, auch konkret auf
ihr Beispiel: Warum nimmst du dein Erbe
nicht an und erhältst diese Investition?
Weil genau diese Investition ist
das, was das größte Gemeinwohl erzeugt.
Erbschaften sollten nicht
umverteilt werden, weil Erben, Vermögen
in Unternehmen gut angelegt,
gemeinnützig angelegt ist. Wenn Menschen Geld
in Unternehmen investieren,
entstehen dadurch Arbeitsplätze und entstehen
dadurch die Gründe für all unsere Steuern,
also all unsere bisherige Umverteilung
basiert darauf, dass Menschen Geld
investieren. Und ein strukturelles Problem
würde jetzt bedeuten, dass du das Geld
nimmst und aufteilst. Aber wo bleiben denn
dann die Investitionen? Woher
kommen dann die Arbeitsplätze von morgen?
Weil der Staat
keine Arbeitsplätze vergibt?
Wo vergibt der Staat produktive
Arbeitsplätze? Ist der Staat der bessere
-Unternehmer für dich?
-Können wir uns darauf einigen, dass jeder
ausreden darf? Vielen Dank. Du
darfst sagen: Ist der Staat der bessere
Unternehmer? War seine Frage.
Wollt ihr darauf antworten?
Mitunter ist der Staat der bessere
Unternehmer. Aber es ist ja keineswegs so,
dass immer nur dieses Kapital
investiert wird. Wir haben die Unternehmenssteuer
gesenkt in Deutschland und die Investitionsquote
blieb niedrig. Da hat
sich nichts getan. Wir haben die Erbschaftssteuer
so reformiert, dass alle
Firmenerben sich da eigentlich jetzt
raustricksen können. Die Investitionsquote
ist niedrig. Was passiert? Das Kapital
mehrt sich an der Börse und es vermehrt
sich bei den Immobilien besonders.
Und das ist ein Kapital, das nicht neue
Arbeitsplätze entstehen lässt, das eher
dafür sorgt, dass viele Leute in prekären
Verhältnissen leben und dafür
arbeiten müssen, dass Erben sehr reich bleiben.
Die Investitionsquote kann sich nicht
mehr wahnsinnig viel erhöhen, weil sie extrem
hoch ist. Unsere Vermögen, die in diesem Land
sind, sind in erster Linie
Betriebsvermögen, in Anleihen und in nicht
selbst genutzten Immobilienvermögen.
Und das ist natürlich genauso auch Betriebsvermögen.
Über drei Viertel aller
Vermögen sind gemeinwohlorientiert
investiert, weil Arbeitsplätze daraus
-entstehen, weil Steuern daraus entstehen.
-Immobilien sind doch nicht
-gemeinwohlorintiert.
-...und unser Staat das umverteilt. Über
die Hälfte dieser Einkommen, die daraus
erwirtschaftet werden, jetzt schon.
Also woher soll denn der Staat dann
das Geld nehmen, das er jetzt umverteilt,
wenn kein Mensch mehr
Immobilien kaufen kann und Betriebe kaufen?
Wieso darf ich entscheiden bei Problemen,
die alle was angehen in einer Demokratie?
Ja, ich finde das gut,
deswegen wird da mein Erbe reingekippt.
Aber muss man schon,
entschuldigung, lasst mich mal ganz kurz, Orry.
Es wird wird von Bedingungen
gesprochen, die sich für einen Großteil
der Bevölkerung einfach nicht ergeben.
Es kann einfach nicht sein, dass wir hier
in Deutschland so viele Menschen haben,
die so hart arbeiten, die sich in prekären
Verhältnissen befinden, keine
Aufstiegschancen haben und dann aber
auf der anderen Seite es Menschen
gibt, die nichts getan haben, keine Leistung
erbracht haben, aber trotzdem
Unsummen an Geldern vererbt bekommen. Und das ist
schlicht und ergreifend ein Problem.
Und da muss dann Vermögen neu gedacht werden.
Wir haben ein zutiefst
strukturelles Problem, das verhindert, dass zu viele
Menschen, die dann eigentlich
anderes versprechen, das die soziale
marktwirtschaftliche Ordnung ergibt,
nämlich aus harter Arbeit kannst du dir
ein kleines Vermögen anschaffen. Und das ist
ja nicht erst seit ein, zwei Jahren
das Problem. Das war schon immer das Problem
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
und das ist besonders eklatant in den marginalisierten
Communitys. Wenn man sich
die 50er Jahre anguckt, die 60er
Jahre anguckt, da sind ganz viele Menschen
aus anderen Ländern hierhergekommen
mit dem Versprechen und die Hoffnung darauf,
dass sie sich hier vielleicht eine bessere
Zukunft aufbauen können. Heute ist
das Vermögen aber nicht in den marginalisierten
Communities anzutreffen.
Und das ist eine riesengroße
Ungerechtigkeit, das kann man so nicht
-stehen lassen.
-Wichtig festzuhalten, Orry, du hast es
geschafft, dass du einen Schritt
nach vorne gegangen bist, Anastasia. Warum?
Weil ich ihm zustimme, dass es nicht
gerecht ist. In Deutschland und nirgendwo
auf der Welt ist es derzeit
gerecht. Die Frage ist: Bringt es was,
wenn wir Privatpersonen
besteuern? Brauchen wir dafür wirklich
diese Erbschaftssteuer und diese Gelder
von einer Person, die über diesem 400 000
Euro Betrag ist? Müssen wir da wirklich
ansetzen bei diesem Mittelstand?
Weil nämlich Superreiche, das sind
die Leute, die meistens Geld ins Unternehmen
stecken, die das Geld haben, eine Stiftung
zu gründen, um da z.B. das Geld zu lagern
und damit keine Steuern zahlen zu müssen.
Das heißt, die Leute umgehen das ja.
Das heißt, da stimme ich euch
eindeutig zu, dass wir wirklich dahin gehen müssen
und gucken müssen, wer umgeht diese Steuern?
Welche Unternehmen versuchen Geld
zu verstecken und in Steuerparadiese
zu flüchten?
Anastasia, erstmal Respekt, du hast
es geschafft, dass jetzt drei Leute so
ein kleines bisschen halb mutig nach vorne
gegangen sind. Aber bleiben wir doch mal
bei dem Mittelstandsargument. Wir müssen,
glaube ich, ein bisschen differenzieren.
Es gibt die Superreichen, wo sich
viel Vermögen konzentriert. Da habt ihr schon
die Machtfrage gestellt. Es gibt
aber auch den Mittelstand, du bist selber
Familienunternehmer, die berechtigt
oder nicht berechtigt, das können
wir diskutieren, Angst davor haben,
dass zum Beispiel eine höhere Erbschaftssteuer
dazu führt, dass weniger investiert
wird, dass weniger tatsächlich unternommen wird
und tatsächlich vielleicht auch weniger
Arbeitsplätze entstehen. Das Argument ist
ja erstens nicht ganz neu, aber auch gar
nicht so unplausibel, Wolfgang, oder?
Da ist schon etwas dran. Deswegen muss
ja auch eine Erbschaftssteuer bei Unternehmen
so aussehen, dass man nicht die Situation
schafft, dass die Erben einfach sagen
"Dann muss ich alles verscherbeln
und dann ist alles weg." Sondern es gäbe ja
die Möglichkeit, eine sehr hohe
Erbschaftssteuer einzuführen, aber
die wird dann gestundet
abgezahlt, so wie man z.B. Bafög abzahlen muss.
Das geschieht ja auch nicht im ersten
Berufsjahr, sondern über eine gewisse
-Zeit.
-Mich würde mal interessieren, was Roland
sagt. Orry hat gesagt, es gibt
ein strukturelles Problem. Ein offenbar
wachsender Teil der Bevölkerung
kann es sich gar nicht mehr leisten,
Vermögen anzusparen während tatsächlich,
das ist ja nun ein Faktum, Vermögen sich
immer weiter
konzentriert. Überzeugt dich das?
Orry würde ich sagen, dass wenn jemand
60, 70, 80 Stunden arbeitet und sich nichts
ansparen kann oder investieren
kann, dann kann er nicht mit Geld umgehen.
-Da das ein ganz anderes Problem.
-Sag das mal einem Kurierfahrer. Das ist
-total neoliberales Gerede, sorry.
-Nein. Einfach nein.
Ich habe selbst 60, 70, 80
Stunden gearbeitet und habe es geschafft,
was auf die Seite legen zu können.
Ich komme aus ganz einfachen Verhältnissen.
-Das ist ein Strukturproblem.
-Wir lassen Roland ganz kurz ausreden.
-Danach dürft ihr antworten.
-Ich kam mit Null her. Ich habe mir alles
selbst aufgebaut und ich bin während der Schulzeit
jeden Tag arbeiten gegangen.
Ich bin nach der Schulzeit arbeiten
gegangen usw.. Also wer sagt, er arbeitet
und kann nicht Geld sparen,
dann hat er irgend ein anderes Problem.
Wenn es um eine höhere
Erbschaftssteuer geht, bin ich der Meinung, dass sehr viel
aus Neid und Hate gesprochen wird
und wir leben vor allem in Deutschland
und Österreich in einer Neidgesellschaft
und da ist einem lieber, der Nachbar hat
auch nichts, weil ich nichts habe.
Anstatt dass ich sage, ich freue mich für dich,
ich möchte das auch anstreben, wenn ich denn
auch will und kann mir das selbe
-aufbauen.
-Du sagst, jeder, der arbeiten will und
Vermögen aufbauen
will, könnte es auch tun?
Klar. Ich kann das von mir auch sagen,
ich habe bei Null gestartet, also bei Minus
und habe mir etwas aufgebaut. Ich bin
Taxi gefahren, ich war ein Zeitungsbote,
ich war Kellner neben meinem
Hauptberuf und habe mir eben meinen Lebensstandard
niedrig gehalten,
damit ich viel ansparen kann.
Kannst du nachvollziehen, dass es Leute
gibt, die genauso fleißig sind wie du
und es trotzdem nicht schaffen
können, weil sie zum Beispiel einen anderen
-Background haben?
-Nein, nicht weil sie einen anderen
Background haben, sondern weil sie über
ihren Verhältnissen leben.
Aber sie leben nicht über ihre Verhältnisse.
Es gibt Jobs, wo es einfach
nicht viel Geld gibt. Eine Krankenschwester
kann sich das nicht
-erarbeiten.
-Wenn ich nur 1000 Euro verdiene, dann
-arbeite ich doch nicht dort.
-Aber es sind doch systemrelevante Jobs,
das hat sich doch gezeigt. Wir können
ja nicht alle nur noch mit Bitcoins handeln
-und Autos vermieten.
-Aber jeder kann selbst entscheiden, was er
-arbeitet.
-Jetzt mal unabhängig davon. Ich weiß, ihr
seid alle nicht der Meinung Rolands,
dass jeder, der will, auch viel Vermögen
ansparen kann. Das wird wohl
ein Streitpunkt zwischen euch bleiben.
Aber wenn wir darüber reden, dass ja,
ich glaube, die Hälfte des vererbten Vermögens
gar nicht aus Arbeit und aus Lohnarbeit
entstanden ist, sondern Vermögen weiter
vererbt wird. Also leistungsloses
Vermögen. Das widerspricht doch eurer
-Argumentation.
-Jedes Vermögen musste irgendwann erspart
werden. Also jedes Vermögen ist
irgendwann einmal nicht konsumierte Einnahme gewesen.
Also irgendjemand hat in einer Geschichte
von Generationen irgendwann einmal gesagt
"Nein, ich konsumiere jetzt nicht,
ich lege es auf die Seite, das Geld."
Und derjenige hat das getan, weil er in seiner
Familie Verantwortung übernehmen
-will.
-Einspruch.
Und diese Leistung hat der erbracht.
Und die Leistung wollen wir hinterher dann
irgendwann nicht mehr gelten lassen.
Und diese Leistung hat jemand dann übernommen
und der konnte das aber auch nur erhalten,
indem er es wieder investiert hat.
Meine Vorfahren, ganz sicher
werden sie sich nicht gedacht haben "Ach,
ich verzichte jetzt, damit ich das Vermögen
irgendwie vermehren kann."
Das ist mehr die Logik "Du als Arbeiter
verzichtest jetzt, damit ich mein Vermögen
vermehren kann." So funktioniert es.
Aber wir arbeiten arbeitsteilig in unserer
Gesellschaft, und das bedeutet, es gibt
nicht so etwas wie ein Vermögen,
das einer sich ausgekaspert
hat, sondern da haben alle Anteil dran,
-die Mitarbeiter.
-Dafür gibt's Lohn. Dafür gibt es Lohn.
Und das bedeutet, es muss sich
entsprechend in der Primärverteilung,
ich bin noch nicht fertig, in der Primärverteilung
sich niederschlagen.
Und das ist nicht der Fall. Jetzt
haben wir das Pflaster Steuergerechtigkeit,
dass das Problem der Primärverteilung
zwar nicht löst, aber wenigstens mal ein bissl
eine Ruhe reinbringen kann, damit wir uns
ernsthaft darüber unterhalten: Was hat
Arbeit und Menschenwürde eigentlich
gemeinsam und wie können wir ein System
aufbauen und weiter bearbeiten mit den bestehenden
Institutionen und Strukturen?
Die demokratischen öffentlichen
Strukturen, wo wir ein Auge drauf haben,
wo wir uns nicht drauf verlassen
müssen, dass irgendein CEO macht, was vielleicht
richtig ist, weil der sich einbildet,
er weiß es besser. Sondern wir müssen uns
anschauen: Was haben wir? Wie kann
man das nutzbar machen und wie kann man fair
sein in der Verteilung? Das bedeutet
momentan, dass die strukturelle
Ungleichheit ausgeglichen werden
muss, dass alle wirklich behaupten können,
sie hätten eine faire
Chance. Weil das ist nicht der Fall.
Entschuldigung, jetzt darf
Gerd antworten. Und danach darfst du.
Marlene, warum nimmst du nicht dein Erbe,
führst das Unternehmen weiter und zahlst
-höhere Löhne?
-Das Unternehmen ist nicht mehr in
Familienbesitz seit 97, deswegen gibt
es ja ein Erbe. Und das andere ist: Wer bin
ich? Der König oder was? Darf ich jetzt
entscheiden? Das ist die Machtfrage.
-Du bist der Unternehmer.
-Nein, ich bin die Erbin.
Also zum einen ist das auch eine absurde
Logik zu sagen "Naja, dann gibt doch
höhere Löhne." Also du gehst davon
aus, dass dann jeder, der ein Unternehmen
geerbt hat oder so, dann auch Bock
drauf hat, die Löhne zu erhöhen.
Als Gewerkschafter erlebe ich auch gerade
in Deutschland: Unglaublich viele
Unternehmen beginnen Tarifflucht.
Sie unterschlagen Löhne, wenn wir Tönnies,
die Fleischereibranche anschauen, dass die ganz
viele Menschen aus Leiharbeitsfirmen
benutzen, um dann alles zu drücken.
Dann denk ich mir so, dann ist
das ein sehr naiver Ansatz zu sagen:
Naja gut, dann nimm doch dein Erbe und bezahle
deinen Mitarbeiterinnen dann einfach
mehr Lohn. Nein, das ist halt auch nicht
die Lösung. Das muss
strukturell angegangen werden.
Wie würdest du es prozentual
einschätzen? Wieviel wird ausgebeutet und wieviel wird
-einfach ordentlich bezahlt?
-Die große Mehrheit wird ganz klar
-ausgebeutet.
-Die große Mehrheit wird ausgebeutet? Und
deswegen verdienen wir immer
mehr Staatseinnahmen aus der Lohnsteuer,
-deswegen haben wir...
-Lasst uns versuchen nicht bei Mutmaßungen
zu bleiben, sondern vielleicht bei den großen
Dingen. Roland hat sich die ganze
-Zeit gemeldet.
-Ja, genau, Ungleichheit. Wenn das bei Geld
anfängt, dann könnte man ja auch sagen
bei Behinderungen. Weil ein Mensch ohne Beine
hat ja auch vielleicht weniger
Vorteile. Also wo geht das dann hin? Ein Schwarzer,
ein Weißer, mit einem Auge. Müsste
man dann jedem, der Augen hat, die Augen
-ausstechen, weil es ist ungleich?
-Ich bin schwarz und schwerbehindert,
-entschuldigung, sorry.
-Ja aber umgekehrt ist es ja schon, weil
wenn ich arm bin, hab ich die Möglichkeit,
vor allem in Deutschland mehr zu arbeiten,
mehr zu investieren und ein Vermögen
daraus zu machen. Aber ich hab's doch
-geschafft.
-Ich bin schwarz und ich bin
schwerbehindert. Und ich hatte scheiß
Einstiegschancen. Ich hatte fast gar keine
Möglichkeiten, neben der Schule noch
irgendwie lernen zu können oder irgendwie
-nochmal einen Nebenjob machen zu können.
-Glaube ich dir.
Weil mich meine Behinderung
zurückgehalten hat. Aber es gibt wenig bis gar keine
Möglichkeiten, genau diese strukturelle
Benachteiligung auszugleichen.
Wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise von diesen 300
Milliarden schätzungsweise dann halt
300 mehr abschöpfen würden, dann
können wir auch an solchen Punkten Gleichheit
schaffen, sodass die Menschen
aufsteigen können. Und so ist das halt nur ein leeres
-Versprechen.
-Glaubst du, wenn wir jetzt beide Null
-haben, haben wir die gleichen Chancen?
-Nein, natürlich nicht. Alleine schon weil
-ich als Schwarzer diskriminiert werde.
-Aber das wäre jetzt wieder ein anderes
-Thema.
-Nee, das hängt zusammen damit.
Wir haben aber auch nicht
die gleichen Chancen, weil ich war
auf einer Privatschule und ich kann
jede Institution betreten, als würde sie mir
-gehören, weil ich so erzogen wurde.
-Also wir reden hier über
Chancengerechtigkeit oder bessere
Chancengerechtigkeit.
Ich will das nochmal mit dieser Chancengerechtigkeit
sagen. Wo ist
der Unterschied, wenn wir beide
geniale Erfinder sind? Ich habe null Euro und du
hast eine Million, dann hast du
den unglaublichen Vorteil, dass du sofort
dein Unternehmen aufbauen kannst. Ich muss
jemand suchen, der mir Kapital gibt
und ich werde vielleicht niemanden
finden, weil ich keinen berühmten Namen habe.
Das ist nämlich genau der Punkt.
Und um nochmal das konkrete Beispiel
aufzugreifen: Wenn du Erbschaftssteuer
zahlen musst, dann hat der Staat mehr Geld
und kann dieses z.B. für Studenten aus prekären
Verhältnissen ausgeben. Und damit
profitieren die, die weniger haben,
davon, dass du Erbschaftssteuer zahlst.
Du hast das vorhin erwähnt, du
kannst nicht entscheiden, wo das Geld hingeht.
Aber dafür haben wir die Demokratie.
Demokratische Entscheidungsprozesse gehen
uns alle was an. Wir dürfen uns
reinbasteln in den Staat. Wir können
mitentscheiden, was wir bei einem
Unternehmen nicht können. Wir können nicht
mitentscheiden, wie die das machen.
Wir müssen uns diesem Wohlwollen ausliefern.
Genau das Gleiche gilt für Philanthropie.
Wenn Bill Gates sich morgen überlegt
"Waffen sind so cool!", dann mach
das. Aber der Punkt ist: Beim Staat haben
wir die demokratische
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten. Da sehen
wir jedes Mal, wenn jemand
Mist baut, weil wir transparent sind,
weil wir eine öffentliche Hand haben,
die drauf guckt und da können wir mitmischen,
wie es verteilt wird. Da können
wir reinbasteln in die Entscheidungen,
was wichtig ist, weil wir alle
gemeinsam entscheiden, was wichtig ist,
und das können wir nicht,
wenn es Einzelmenschen gibt, die
in Einzelpositionen einzeln Macht
ausüben in einer Art und Weise, die an einem
feudalistischen System dran
ist. Und das ist, was wir haben.
Dem muss widersprochen
werden. Wir sind eine Marktwirtschaft.
In einer Marktwirtschaft kann Eigentum
nur dann erhalten werden, wenn es gemeinwohl
produktiv ist. Nur dann, wenn ich es investiere,
sodass hintenraus Produkte
entstehen, die irgendjemand haben
will und die auch irgendjemand kauft,
-Kauf dich glücklich.
-bleibt es mein Eigentum. Wenn ich Produkte
produziere, die keiner kaufen
will, warum kauft jemand diese Produkte
offensichtlich? Es gibt nichts
demokratischeres als den Markt. Der Markt
entscheidet frei darüber, was er haben
will und was nicht. Und da bleibt hinten
heraus das Eigentum erhalten, das Bedürfnisse
befriedigt, Nutzen schafft.
-Katharina Pistor "Der Code des Kapitals"
-Der Unternehmer hängt ausschließlich vom
Wohlwollen des Marktes ab. Das heißt,
er ist der Schwächste in der Machtposition.
Jetzt hast du am Ende, Gerd, nochmal
schön alle nach hinten getrieben. Wir sind
tatsächlich aber jetzt trotzdem in der Phase:
Das Ziel dieser Sendung ist,
einen Kompromiss zu finden. Und ich weiß,
hier sind Gemüter aufeinander geprallt.
Es wurde auch hitzig, vollkommen klar.
Trotzdem bitte ich euch: Geht mal in euch
und versucht drüber nachzudenken, wie schaffe
ich es vielleicht auch über meinen
eigenen Schatten zu springen und vielleicht
einen Schritt auf die anderen
zuzugehen? Was müssten die vorschlagen?
Was könntet ihr vorschlagen? Also wir sind
jetzt in einer Art Kompromissrunde
angekommen. Vielleicht kommen wir ja noch
ein bisschen näher zusammen. Mein Vorschlag
ist jetzt: Das bisherige System
mit großzügigen Freibeträgen und dem Schutz
für Familienunternehmen bleibt
erhalten. Vielleicht bauen wir sogar
Freibeträge aus, sodass am Ende kein
Unternehmen irgendwie Gefahr läuft,
einen Arbeitsplatz oder eine Innovationskraft
zu verlieren. Das Geld aber was dann,
da kommen wir zu den Superreichen,
vielleicht das, was dann noch weit
drüber liegt, wird höher besteuert. Das heißt,
wir heben den Erbschaftssteuersatz an und weiten
aber die Freibeträge vielleicht
sogar noch weiter aus. Wenn ihr sagt
ja, es ist zumindest mal ein Anfang,
dann würde ich euch bitten, kommt
einen Schritt nach vorne, so wie es Anastasia
gerade tut. Und wenn ihr das nicht
sagt, dann bleibt einfach stehen. Ihr bleibt
-alle stehen.
-Generation Z ist entscheidend offener für
-Vorschläge.
-Warum wäre das nichts für dich?
Erbschaftssteuer
erhöhen, Freibeträge auch?
Also ich finde schon, die Freibeträge
sind so, wie die gerade sind. Aber da bin
ich natürlich Laie. Dass sie hoch
genug sind, als dass ich da jetzt irgendwie
sagen würde Ja, unterstütze ich. Ok,
fair enough. Jetzt seid ihr dran. Also merkt
euch bitte, wo ihr steht. Und dann
steckt ihr bitte mal die Köpfe zusammen
und versucht irgendwie die Gegenseite
zu überzeugen. Wenn das klappt...
Und es werden strukturell
immer die gleichen "beausnahmt".
Also mit 100 Millionen ist man ja
nicht reich. Also jung schon, natürlich.
So, jetzt wird hier rechts und links
noch fleißig diskutiert. Was für eine Folge,
oder? Ja, was wäre denn euer Vorschlag?
Wie könnten diese beiden Gruppen
mit welchem Kompromissvorschlag näher
zusammenkommen? Ob das heute noch klappt?
-Unter dieser Bedingung dann halt einfach.
-Ich schlage vor, Gruppe Grün fängt an. Was
-ist euer Kompromissvorschlag?
-Also dieses Thema Chancengerechtigkeit ist
fraglos die wichtigste
Gerechtigkeit in einer freiheitlichen Gesellschaft.
Und dafür muss der Staat Geld in die Hand
nehmen. Und wenn wir dafür mehr Geld
investieren müssen, dann bitte nicht
von der Substanz, sondern vom Mehrwert.
Der Mehrwert ist der Gewinn oder das Einkommen.
Also wenn, dann müssen wir über
höhere Gewinnbesteuerung, wo wir schon
ganz oben sind, und höhere
Einkommenssteuern, wo man auch schon
relativ weit oben sind. Aber wenn,
dann müssen wir über das nachdenken,
nicht über die Besteuerung der Substanz.
Ausgerechnet Gerd schlägt vor "höhere
Gewinne und Einkommenssteuern".
Ne, man steht ja eher damit noch den Unternehmern,
die anfangen, die kein Geld
im Rücken haben, im Wege. Also die besteuert
man jetzt plötzlich stärker,
wo man ja vielleicht wirklich
noch sagen kann, da wird was geleistet.
Und warum soll man nicht gerade da das Geld
nehmen, was einfach nur einem
-in den Schoß fällt?
-Okay, also ihr geht nicht nach vorne. Alle
3 nicht, hab ich richtig verstanden?
Okay, also bis jetzt sind noch nicht ganz so
viele nach vorne gekommen. Aber jetzt
habt ihr einen Vorschlag. Vielleicht schafft
-ihr es ja noch.
-Unser Vorschlag ist, dass wir bei den 400
000 Freibetrag bleiben für Privatleute,
die dann erben, übrigens dann auch nicht
mehr an Familie gebunden. Denn wir leben
nicht mehr in dynastischen Zeiten.
Wir sagen aber dann, dass das Erbe
darüber hinaus so versteuert werden muss
wie das Einkommen. Und genauso
progressiv. Und wir sagen auch: Niemand muss mehr
als eine Millionen Euro erben. Niemand
braucht mehr Geld. Und bei den Firmen wird
es so sein, dass die das stunden
können, dass die das nicht auf einmal bezahlen
müssen und dass es auch die Bedingung
gibt, dass diese Firmen sich an die Tarife
halten und dass sie sich auch mit den Gewerkschaften
abstimmen. Und diese Steuer
wird zweckgebunden
sein für Bildung und Klima.
-Zweckgebundene Steuer.
-Das ist kein Kompromissvorschlag, das ist
die Vernichtung des
Familienunternehmertums.
Nur um das zu verstehen, ich versuche
erst einmal zu verstehen. Das heißt,
niemand muss mehr als eine Millionen
Euro haben. Das heißt ab einer Million Euro 100
-Prozent Erbschaftssteuer?
-Genau. Es gab in den Siebzigerjahren mal
einen Präsidentschaftskandidaten in den USA,
der wollte genau das einführen,
sogar schon ab 500 000. Wir sind
also sehr großzügig heute aber.
Zumal Erbschaftssteuer nur eine von vielen
Vermögenssteuern sind,
die wir als Gesamtpaket brauchen,
um dafür zu sorgen, dass wir strukturelle
Gleichstellung haben, damit
wir überhaupt davon sprechen können,
dass wir marktwirtschaftlich
arbeiten, weil wenn wir nicht am gleichen Stockerl
anfangen, enden wir auch nicht
am gleichen.
Kurze Frage. Ich wollte nur mich
erkundigen. In dieser einen Millionen:
Sind da Gegenstände dabei
oder geht es nur ums Barvermögen?
-Nein, Vermögen. Das ganze Vermögen.
-Okay, also auch ein Ring-Erbe, der viel
wert ist, weil er Gold ist, mit Diamanten
besetzt, der ist dann schon drin.
-Oder ein Picasso.
-Dann muss ich leider zurückgehen.
-Oder sonstige Ausbeutungsmöglichkeiten.
-Das bedeutet eine total Verstaatlichung
alles Unternehmertums. Dann sind wir 100
Prozent im Kollektivismus, im Marxismus.
Nein, bei den Vermögen ist es ja
anders. Bei den Vermögen wollen wir eine hohe
Erbschaftssteuer haben, eine höhere
als jetzt auch für die Familienunternehmen.
Aber die können das durch ihre Profite
nach und nach abzahlen. Aber die sollen
natürlich nicht abrasiert werden,
sondern die haben die Möglichkeit, dann über
ihre Profite eine ordentliche
Erbschaftssteuer zu zahlen. Und das können
die ja schaffen, denn ich glaube
an unsere deutschen Familienunternehmen.
Zumal es gibt auch stille
Beteiligungen, Stundung, Kredite. Alles, was einem
normalen Menschen zumutbar ist,
ist auch einem Unternehmer zumutbar.
Das heißt, diese Grenze gilt auch für Unternehmen,
die eine Millionengrenze?
-Und ab da muss ich...
-Nettovermögen, Schuldenabzug.
Okay. Gut, der Vorschlag steht im Raum.
Roland versucht, hinten den Ausweg
-zu finden.
-Die Tür.
Was mir nicht in den Kopf reingeht:
Wir werden erzogen in diesem kapitalistischen
System: Leistung soll belohnt werden.
So. Ungefähr. Es gibt ja Studien, die sagen
wir, ungefähr 300 Milliarden.
Uns gehen 300 Milliarden an Einnahmen,
die wir für die Gesellschaft, für das Gemeinwohl.
Wir müssen ja nicht alle 300
Milliarden. Aber wir können doch
deutlich mehr als 7, 8 oder 10 Milliarden
einnehmen, um dann für das Gemeinwohl
was zu machen. Und diesen Widerstand,
der vor allem von privilegierten
Menschen kommt. Das verstehe ich halt einfach
-nicht.
-Das ist nicht der Widerstand gegen das
Gemeinwohl und gegen die Menschen,
sondern ich glaube, dass dieses Geld
bei den Unternehmen Gemeinwohl
nützlicher angelegt ist, weil die nämlich
Arbeitsplätze damit schaffen, bei denen
sie Gewinne machen, womit dann wieder
-Steuern daraus erwirtschaftet werden.
-Ja aber dann hätten wir doch nicht so eine
große soziale Ungleichheit
gerade, aber die ist ja gerade da.
-Aber wir haben keine...
-Doch, die ist größer als in den
vergangenen Jahren, das ist
ein großes Problem gerade.
-Nein, nein.
-Doch. Aber da finden wir wieder einen
Punkt, wo wir uns darauf einigen
können, dass wir uns nicht darauf einigen können.
Man kann sich ja
verschiedenste Modelle, die es gibt, anschauen
und gemeinschaftlich diskutieren.
Ich würde es nicht vorgeben wollen, aber
es gibt z.B. Thomas Piketty, der sagt,
5 Prozent des Staatshaushalts lassen sich
aus Vermögenssteuern lukrieren und kann
man dann umverteilen, sodass jeder Mensch
zum 25. Geburtstag ein Erbe bekommt
von 120 oder 125 000. Es ist eine Möglichkeit
von vielen umzuverteilen und wir müssen
sie uns alle anschauen und gut auskaspern,
wie man es macht, aber
gemeinsam demokratisch und nicht ich,
-die es vorgibt.
-Da würde ich ergänzen. Ich finde z.B.,
dass um wirklich
Gleichberechtigung zu schaffen, finde ich, ich darf
das bekommen, was meine Mutter
verdient hat, verzichte dafür aber auf dieses Erbe
vom Staat. Und dafür bekommt
vielleicht eine andere Person aus finanziell
schwächeren Haushalten, die ganz
viele Chancen nicht hatte, die ich hatte,
die bekommt dann vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr. Das fände ich schön, weil  damit
-wäre dann Gerechtigkeit.
-Dafür braucht man Daten, wer denn wie viel
-hat, die wir auch nicht haben.
-Genau. Transparenz in der Politik,
Transparenz zu Unternehmen,
Transparenz, wie viel sie einnehmen.
-Genau, also Transparenz.
-Transparenz.
Demokratie,
Transparenz, Steuergerechtigkeit jetzt.
-Wir sind uns einig, wow.
-Naja.
-Komm schon, zerstöre nicht den Moment.
-Das ist jetzt eine Folge gewesen, wo ich,
wenn ich der Kompromissonkel sein will,
relativ gescheitert bin. So oder so hilft
es euch vielleicht trotzdem, euch eine eigene
Meinung zu bilden. Denn ich glaube,
die Argumente, und das ist ja ein großer
Teil dieser Sendung, sind hoffentlich klar
geworden. Dankeschön. Wie auch immer
man zu diesem Thema steht, im Kampf
gegen die soziale Ungleichheit
erscheint die Erbschaftssteuer ein geeigneteres
Mittel zu sein als z.B. die Vermögenssteuer,
die viel bürokratischer
und komplexer daherkommt. So
oder so müssen wir von allen Parteien
in diesem Bundestagswahlkampf
erwarten können, dass sie sich glasklar
positionieren. Wie wollen sie die Steuer
erhöhen? Und wenn sie sie gar nicht
erhöhen wollen, dann müssen sie wenigstens
sagen, warum nicht. Auch ihr solltet
natürlich eine Position finden. Und wenn euch
13 Fragen gefällt, dann könnt
ihr hier unseren Kanal abonnieren.
Hier findet ihr eine weitere Folge 13 Fragen
und hier gibt's ein weiteres Video zum
Thema.